في موضوع الصحه النفسيه اليوم نتحدث عن
اضطراب فرط الحركه وتشتت الانتباه لكن
هالمره ليس لدى الاطفال بل عند البالغين
وثائقيين للبي بي سي مشاهدينا اثار الجدل
حول زياده المترددين على العيادات النفسيه
وتشخيصهم باضطراب اي دي اتش دي بعد بل تصل
قوائم الانتظار تخيلوا لسنوات مع هذه
الزياده ارتفع ايضا استهلاك عقاقير فرط
الحركه وتشتت الانتباه خاصه في فتره
الامتحانات ما اثر شكوكا ايضا حول تحول
الموضوع الى تجاره نشيطه هذا هو الخوف
بالفعل لانه هناك راي طبي يقول ان اعراض
الاي دي اتش دي قد تؤثر لفتره وتختفي
بينما يقول اخرون ان التشخيص ليس عبر
الاعراض بل في مدى وضوحها في استراليا
هاجم النجم هارلي بونر من يدعون اصابتهم
بهذه الحاله خاصه بعد تكرارها وقال انه
سئم منهم وان مشاكل تشتت تركيزهم بسبب
ادمانهم يوتيوب وانستجرام خلينا نروح لي
على سرحان معه ارقام احصائيات جهينه صباح
العربيه علاء لديك الخبر اليقين شكرا عادل
وراويه تشير التقارير الى ان تشخيص اضطراب
نقص الانتباه مع فرط النشاط اصبح اكثر
شيوعا وايضا ارتفاع في عدد وصفات الادويه
المستخدمه لعلاجه وفقا لمؤسسه اي دي اتش
دي الخيريه في بريطانيا يعاني نحو مليونير
و600 الف شخص في المملكه المتحده من هذه
الحاله وهذا يشكل ما نسبته ثلاثه الى
اربعه في المئه من السكان البالغين تشير
المؤسسه الى زياده قدرها 400 في المئه في
عدد الاشخاص البالغين الذين يسعون الى
التشخيص منذ عام 2020 في الولايات المتحده
وبين عامي
16 و2020 بقيت نسبه السكان الذين حصلوا
على وصفه طبيه لعقار منشط هذه النسبه كانت
ثابته نسبيا لكن شهد عام 2021 زياده
ملحوظه حيث قفزت الوصفات الطبيه باكثر من
10% في غالبيه الفئات العمريه لتصل النسبه
الى اثنين ونصف في المئه من البالغين
الامريكيين الذين قد يكونوا يعانون من
اضطراب فرط الحركه ونقص الانتباه
[موسيقى]
ناديه منصور اهلا بك دكتوره معنا دكتوره
ناديه في صباح العربيه
دكتور عناديه الاي دي اتش دي يعني اربع
احرف بدنا منسمعها بشكل هائل في السنوات
الاخيره
هل بالفعل زادت حالات الاصابه بفرط الحركه
وقله التركيز
لغايه لهذه الدرجه حتى انها تصيب البالغين
كمان ولا انها زمان ما كانت مشخصه واصبحت
مشخصه الان لا هو اضطراب
وده اللي هو معناه
الحركه ونقص الانتباه ده اضطراب عصبي نفسي
بيولد به الشخص واسبابه جينيه وبعض
الاسباب الاخرى
فهو لازم يكون من الطفوله يعني يعني هو
قله تشخيص فقط
الب الان اللي كان طفل كان موجود معه وهو
طفل ولكن ما تم تشخيصه طيب كيف لماذا هذه
هذه الارقام اللي تدعو الى زياده هل هي
بصحيح بسبب اليوتيوب انستغرام مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بسبب اخر طبعا
ده على الانترنت والناس بتقرا في جوجل
وحتى الناس اللي بيقولوا في العياده يقول
انا عندي مشاكل في التركيز ومشاكل كذا كذا
وقريت لقيت الاعراض ماشيه مع الايد اتش دي
فالسوشيال ميديا
والانترنت اكيد او التشخيص الوهمي انجاز
التعبير بالنسبه هو يشخص نفسه
حسب التقييم يعني احنا بننهم تقييم هل
هناك اسباب معروفه ليش الناس تصاب بالاي
دي اتش دي وكما ذكرتي بانه على الاغلب
يعني منذ الولاده اللي بيكتشفوا انه عندهم
كبالغين
بالفعل عندهم انه هن صغار بس شو اسبابه
جينيه ام اسلوب حياه ام شيء يحصل في وقت
الحمل هو اسبابه يعني الابحاث اثبتت انه
اسبابه جنيه وراثيه حتى ممكن يمشي في
عائلات
ده لسبب الاساسي
واكتشفوا ان هي في ماده اسمها الدوبامين
بتبقى في القشره الاماميه في
الدماغ ودي مسؤوله عن الانتباه والتخطيط
والتركيز
ووضع الخطوط دكتوره ناديه من يعاني من قله
الترق التركيز وتشتت الانتباه ياخذ ايه
بحسب هو تشخص اللي هو العاديات
لازم تكون مقصره على حياته في الناحيه
الاكاديميه من ناحيه العمل من ناحيه
العلاقات مع الاخرين ففي الحاله دي يفضل
انه يبدا ياخد دواء ففي طبعا ادويه وفي
علاج سلوكي علاج سلوكي
ان هم بنعلمهم مهارات التخطيط مهارات كيف
ينظم وقته
كيف
يتعلم الاسترخاء لانه
بشكرك جزيلا الشكر اختصاصيه الطب النفسي
دكتوره ناديه منصور كانت معنا في
الاستوديو على هذه المعلومات المفيده
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات